[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment hey
guys the first official game of thrones
season a teaser included a detail
description of the opening scene the
largest battle scene ever filmed for not
only Game of Thrones but for the
television in general and the mysterious
scene from the very finale we have
already seen the opening scene as well
as the Battle of NFL and going in the
final episode of Game of Thrones there's
only left this mysterious scene that
will take place in it
let's take a look at the scene from the
finale that might be confirming some of
my most popular theories in which Ned
Stark could be alive an exclusive
Entertainment Weekly report the
description of this mysterious scene
from the series finale says what's being
filmed here is episode 6 the series
finale like Harrington going into the
table read I don't know anything about
the final season storyline I look around
at the meticulously constructed said
that I've never seen on the show before
several actors are performing and I'm
stunned they're characters in the finale
that I did not expect I gradually begin
to piece together what is happening
Westeros of the previous five episodes
and try not to look like I'm freaking
out it's noted that their characters in
the last episode of Game of Thrones he
did not expect now we don't know if this
means their characters we did not expect
in terms of them surviving the long or
if it means there are some unexpected
characters reappearing in the very last
episode it could very well be just one
of the main characters surviving more
than we expected but would it really
lead the reporter stunts his stunts he's
freaking out about his character
appearing in a series finale meaning
that it's probably a character no one
expects coming back in the series ever
again
additionally I think it's probably a
character who we think is dead
reappearing and leaving us in shock with
that being said let's take a look at who
might be this character whose presence
in Game of Thrones finale will leave us
stunned and make us freaked out as my
most popular theory states it could be
that fans favorite character Ned Stark
is not dead but his rather alive and
will finally reappear over a year ago
introduced with a theory in which fans
favorite character Ned Stark is not dead
but rather alive I've never really been
into theorists in which someone with so
dying is actually alive but I came up to
this theory upon watching Game of
Thrones and to me this same theory is
more than convincing that videomic has
been shared by many popular mainstream
media from his first UK to Metro UK
and metropolitan the theory itself is
supported with quite a few hints and
clues that it made everyone think twice
about what they know or what they
thought they knew the season 7 even
provided a small clue that is going
favor to net start being alive and so I
decided to update this theory before
introduce to be this new hinting clue
let's first take a look on the clues we
had before about the possibility of the
most honorable man in the Seven Kingdoms
Eddard Stark being alive this whole time
this theory is not about the possibility
of Ned Stark working into one of the
birds that flew above him in the
execution scene or about anything that
has to do with working in this theory
Amanda was beheaded by surreal in pain
on the steps of great Sept of Baelor was
not actually net himself but was jocking
Hegar bearing Ned's face I know that at
first it probably sounds unbelievable
but give me a few moments explain it as
we all know head upon trying to carry
out the justice and Robert's well was
betrayed by Slynt and Baelish whereupon
he was imprisoned in the black cells
beneath the red keep while at the same
time there was also Jackie Cogan a
mysterious man that was introducing
himself as a lorathi criminal and who
was also arrested in Boonton dungeons
once he found out who'd already criminal
by the name of Jackie Cogan real is a
faceless man assassin we've all been
wondering why he got himself arrested we
know that he did it on purpose
and got himself in the dungeons clearly
on purpose well according to this theory
a faceless man assessee most highly paid
for his service which in this case will
be helping Ned Stark avoid certain death
no it's not what you're probably
thinking right now Jackie did not switch
face with Ned he switched it with Syrio
Forel
this point you're probably confused
which I understand but just pay for a
couple of moments as we all know Syrio
Forel is a master swordfighter from the
free city of Braavos hired by Ned Stark
to train his daughter Arya upon
discovering his daughter owns a sword
opponent arrest Lannister guard led by
Sir Meryn Trant of the Kingsguard came
for Arya to take her into custody
a scene that ended with Syria engaging
sir Marian with his wooden sword by this
theory Syria did not die as he was still
far better with his wooden sword than a
dozen Lannister guards along with sir
Meryn Trant and according to this theory
syria defeated him the evidence to point
is part of a theory would be a scene in
which the Hound left so hard on her
statement that she learned how to fight
from the first sword brows was
apparently killed by Sir Meryn since her
marriage
a great fighter not even a good one so
this point of the terrier a Ned Stark
and jocking were in cells which matches
with Game of Thrones series
well Syria did not die and was still in
King's Landing and so he decided to help
Ned Stark which could be questionable
but his theory jocking Hegar was
arrested on purpose since I cannot
imagine that the faceless man could have
been arrested against his well Jack he
was arrested on purpose because of Ned
Stark in order to get in the dungeons
and to help him and to sacrifice his
life for Nance
it said that for a good price the cult
of religious assassins that worship the
many fails God will grant the gift of
death to anyone in the world but will
they for a good price offered their own
life for the many-faced God with Jack
him by this theory did is also
questionable according to this theory
Jackie Huck our faceless men created a
face that looked just like Ned's and
worried on the day of Ned's beheading
which would mean that instead of Ned it
was Jackie who died was beheaded in the
front steps of the great Sept of Baelor
as some kind of proof I'm relying on a
scene that took place in the season 5
finale a scene in which a key hug our
warriors face while Laura herself was
standing just beside him this scene
might be confirming that the faceless
man assassins can wear a face of a
person that is not dead of a person
that's still alive since they might be
able to create a mask from matter faces
they could look just like the face of
the person they want to portray if
you're wondering what was serious role
it's actually pretty simple
both joking and Ned were rested and were
in their cells which means that while
jogging agar was portraying Ned then
just before he was beheaded
someone had to release net free and that
someone also had to replace Jacques in
intake Jackie's face since a bit later
was so jacking her car being recruited
by urine to join the Nights Watch so
this point Joe can replace his Loretto
criminal face with Ned's face that he
has created himself well in stark was
released free from his cell with the
help of Syrio Forel which was not that
hard not to mention impossible since
various also could have done the same if
he had wanted let's see what we got so
far
Jackie's beheaded Ned Stark is set free
but who took Jackie's former face so
Dorothy criminal and continued to poor
chain as we saw him being recruited by
urine and as we saw him helping re
numerous times it could be and by this
theory it is Syrio Forel which might be
hinted by the scene there's only manga
then you know his name said jack into
arya
might be a confirmation that Syria took
the face of a faceless man that died
Fernet took a face of jocking hogar this
would explain by jack in told to aria
did she already knows god's name which
she in fact knew because Siri already
had told her during their training
serious said to her there's only one God
and His name is death if this theory
comes true in the final season it will
also explain why Jackie was so
protective towards Aria and why he
taught her to become a skilled fighter
it will also explain how Jackie knew
that Ari already knows the name of one
true God and most importantly what
Jackie Hegar was smiling when Ari said
to him a girl is Arya start from NFL and
I'm going home
upon rereading the books have also found
some kind of a hidden hence they're
going favor to this theory in which
Jackie more Nets face and was beheaded
the first hint would be census claimed
that her father scared about maegor's
holdfast looked weirdly unlike her
father the second hand would be Caitlyn
statement that Ned's bones don't look
like Ned's but rather likes someone
smaller than that and the Lester DN
would be aria statement that Ned on
execution they look different which he
thinks was a result of Ned's injury that
he got from his confrontation with Jaime
but let's face it
I won't it like doesn't change your
facial features I know there are still a
few unanswered questions such as who
paid the faceless men and wasn't hiding
this whole time which could be very
simple considering a scene from the very
first season a scene in which various
visited in prison net from that scene
for the very first time and for the last
time is so very stealing at some one
which he did because he cared about
Nate's life but from that scene we've
also found out from Aires that he was
living in the Free Cities the imports of
those facts that brought you a moment
ago is the very scared for Ned's life he
did not release net himself because of a
simple reason everyone would have known
it was him which gave various only one
choice he had to pay to the faceless man
for his services well Syrio Forel eater
decided on his own to help Ned or was
arranged by various as well now let's
try to solve a location on which Ned
might have gone upon being released my
first guess would be the Free Cities or
more accurately the free city of Pentos
or even more accurately as a guest of
Illyrio mopatis Varys is loyal friend
there's also a possibility of Ned Stark
upon being released estate investors
more precisely in grave on watch the
seat of house Reid whose head is Howland
Reed
ned's loyal friend the field already
save his life once and the only man that
beside Nets a membrane knows they keep
shanshu identity in secret if you're
wondering why am i rejecting a
possibility of net being able to work
into one of the birds that flew above
him in the execution scene well let's
just put it this way apparently the most
important or should I say the only
argument that goes in favor the working
theory is Ned Stark being seen muttering
to himself a moment before he was
beheaded now in my opinion the working
theory is ridiculous in my opinion it
was either the actual net who matter to
him sell the same praise that he was
murdering just the moments before he
executed well a deserter from the Nights
Watch
or if a theory mine come sure it'll mean
the jacket while wearing Nate's face
muttered to himself all men must die
Valar morghulis
as i rewatched already mention ninth
episode of the first season as I was
rewashing man's last words he muttered
to himself it really seems like man's
last words were rather morghulis all men
must die but it would not make any sense
for Ned Stark to say it in his final
moments as it's a common greeting
Bravo's naughty mirror fell not in the
north not a masterís as much as Ned
Stark saying a greeting in high Valyrian
language that is common in Braavos
sounds ridiculous it might be a hearing
hearing that Ned Stark is actually alive
because the natural settlement must die
before his beheading it might be some
kind of proved as going favor to my
theory that brought you over a year ago
what do you think could it be possible
the Ned Stark is the character whose
reappearance in the final episode will
make a stand and in shock and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace